[Música]
un hombre que recibe un disparo a
quemarropa
una familia que huye bajo las balas
[Música]
un periodista asesinado en su auto
las ciudades de mayoría árabe de Israel
están atravesando una ola de violencia
especialmente mortífera al menos 75
personas fueron asesinadas en 2022
delitos que son atribuidos a bandas
criminales más del 70% de los homicidios
de Israel se producen en la comunidad
árabe que solo representa el 20% de la
población el periodista asesinado a
principios de septiembre se llamaba
nidal akbaria
[Música]
este es nuestro observador calle quien
hizo un estudio sobre la violencia en la
comunidad árabe el sábado debido a este
fenómeno todo el mundo se siente
amenazado
esta violencia es causada por
organizaciones criminales organizaciones
que trafican con drogas que extorsionan
a pequeños negocios y a ciertas empresas
[Música]
también existe la práctica de La usur
ilegal un negocio que recauda enorme en
sumas de dinero pedí dinero prestado en
el mercado negro y no pude devolverlo
recibimos amenazas diarias dispararon
contra nuestra casa ahora mi papá mi
mamá mi hermano y mi hermana están en
peligro por favor ayúdennos a devolverlo
le pagaremos Tan pronto como podamos
estamos hablando de un escenario que se
asemeja al de la marca italiana
y se calcula que hay unas 300.000 armas
en circulación
esto es mucho claramente
el aparato de seguridad israelí es muy
poderoso
pero cuando se trata de violencia en la
comunidad árabe la policía no suele
hacer mucho
en agosto 2021 la policía de israelí
creó una unidad especial para combatir
la delincuencia en la comunidad árabe de
israelí la policía afirmó que el número
de asesinatos ha disminuido pero los
habitantes dicen seguir sintiéndose en
peligro los jóvenes palestinos de Israel
entre 18 y 25 años Estamos hablando
entre el 25 Y el 30% de los jóvenes
palestinos del interior están
desempleados estos jóvenes son más
propensos a caer en la delincuencia
hoy en día el delincuente se ha
convertido en un modelo que los jóvenes
tratan de imitarlos
tras la publicación de este estudio en
marzo pusimos en marcha un programa para
intervenir a nivel de los municipios
con proyectos de fomento del empleo y
los valores porque la solución debe ser
social no podemos construir una sociedad
a base de soluciones en materia de
seguridad
la unidad especial de policía denominada
ha informado haber realizado más de
2.000 detenciones desde el año pasado
pero Incluso hoy en día solo el 1 de
cada cinco asesinatos cometidos en la
comunidad árabe es resuelto En
comparación con el 70% de los casos que
afectan a los ciudadanos judíos
[Música]
el arte tradicional del tatuaje maorí
conocido como está moco estaba en
peligro de extinción las autoridades
neozelandesas se forzaron durante la
época colonial para suprimir esta
cultura indígena pero 50 años después el
tamuco está lejos de extinguirse de
hecho a experimentado un Renacimiento
sin precedentes nuestro observador
mocouri Arranke Smith es uno de los
pocos artistas que trabajan para revivir
esta práctica en su cuenta de Instagram
él nos cuenta más para nosotros los
tatuajes son únicamente estéticos hay
que diferenciar entre los tatuajes y el
tamuco el moco es mucho más una
expresión de identidad en el ámbito
cultural
con lazos tribales lazos genealógicos
es casi como una herramienta nemotécnica
de guardar historias en tu cuerpo a las
que puedes referirte
soy uno de los pocos practicantes que
está tratando de revivir esta forma de
arte aquí en este país
en estas Islas es una forma de arte que
se ha perdido solo trabajamos con
herramientas tradicionales no trabajo
con máquinas el proceso de moco abrir la
piel poner algo nuevo y curarlo y
nuestra forma de rearticular quién es
uno en esa etapa de su vida
el trabajo es mucho más significativo
cuando lo hacemos para aquellos que
intentan recuperar el sentido de la
identidad los que intentamos
descolonizarse la práctica del tatuaje
tamoco salió considerablemente afectada
en el siglo 19 20 por la colonización
británica de las Islas los colonos
culparon a los que tenían tatuajes y
durante un tiempo no se les permitió
ejercer a los tatuadores también se
pusieron en peligro otros aspectos de la
cultura maorí Pero según nuestro
observador todo está cambiando esta
renovación fue iniciada por nuestros
mayores hace 40 o 50 años siempre ha
sido el sueño que se convierta en algo
normal y cotidiano
algo celebrado pero normal en estas
Islas
todos forma parte de nuestra
descolonización de esa cultura
el objetivo final es que tengamos una
representación paritaria y equitativa
y que nos representemos de una manera
que no sea fiel
la cultura de Nueva Zelanda está
cambiando muy rápidamente
en los últimos cuatro o cinco años se ha
dado un giro de 180 grados y hay una
aceleración de la integración del mundo
maorí en lo que es Nueva Zelanda
predominantemente blanca
Es realmente emocionante
[Música]
de esta manera llegamos al final de
nuestro programa por esta emisión
recuerde que todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en pantalla para que nos manden
su fotos y videos aficionados hasta una
próxima oportunidad